Hey, everyone.
Welcome to another edition
of YouTube Developers Live.
Today I'll be teaching you
guys some tips and tricks
for debugging your OAuth
token when you just
don't seem to be getting
the right responses.
So why don't we go ahead,
switch to my screen.
I'll show you some
of the tools that I
use when I'm debugging OAuth.
So first off, you'll want to
know about this documentation.
It's on developers.google.com.
It's called, "Using OAuth 2.0
for Client-side Applications."
It's probably easier
if you just search
for this title in your
favorite search engine.
Again, that's "Using OAuth 2.0
for Client-side Applications."
There's a lot of
documentation here.
But really there's one thing
here that we want to get at,
and that is
validating the token.
So when you click
on this link, you'll
see that there's this URL.
And this URL lets us
validate access tokens
and lets us get more
information about the tokens.
So in this case, I'm
going to go ahead and just
copy paste this output
here, this URL here,
and see what happens.
All right?
I'm just copying
this into my browser.
And what you're
going to see back
is that there's going to be
a JSON response that says,
hey, the token's invalid.
So that's because I
just copy pasted this.
In fact, if I give it
some crazy value, abcdef,
you'll see that this is
still an invalid OAuth token.
And that makes sense.
So what happens when we give
it a working OAuth token?
Or one that's semi-working?
Well, first we'll
need to generate one.
And a tool that I like to
use to generate OAuth tokens
is the OAuth Playground.
You can get here by going to
developers.google.com/OAuthPlayground.
Or again, you can search for
this in your favorite search
engine until it comes up.
Now, what I'm going to do is I'm
going to select and authorize
some APIs.
So I'm going to scroll down.
I'm going to look
for YouTube, and I'm
going to select the
YouTube read-only scope.
I'm going to scroll
down to Authorize APIs.
And this is going to put me
through the three-legged OAuth
flow.
I'm going to click Accept.
And you'll see that I've gotten
back an authorization code.
I'm not going to go too much
into the internals of OAuth.
But the authorization
code is something
that your server
would use to exchange
for a refresh token
or an access token.
So if I go ahead and I
click Exchange authorization
code for tokens, it will
populate the Refresh Token
and Access Token fields.
And in the OAuth
2.0 Playground, I
can actually test
certain API calls.
We're not going
to do that today.
Instead, I'm just going
to go back and click
on Exchange authorization
code for tokens.
I'm going to copy
paste the access token.
And I'm going to put
it into this URL.
And you'll see that I'm just
passing it as a URL parameter.
And I get back a lot
more information.
In fact, I see what's the
client ID that got it back.
What's the scope, and
when does it expire,
and what's the access type?
Now, you may or may not
be using an offline token.
So this is one
way to know if you
have an online token
or an offline token.
And remember, an
offline token is one
that you can refresh every
hour, via the refresh token,
and get a new token to
make API calls with.
Now, most of the
time, the API client
will handle this for you.
So a lot of times,
people get confused.
You know, what's an
authorization code?
What's a refresh token?
And the token that you want
to use to be making API calls
is the access token.
So if you accidentally plug
in your refresh token somehow,
you'll see that, hey, this
is not a valid OAuth token.
And what's really
cool about this
is that I can go ahead
and switch to terminal.
And I'm just going to
blow this up right here.
You can also do this in cURL.
Oop!
You're going to have to
give it some quotes there.
And what's nice about this
is that any HTTP client
can handle this
operation for you.
So one possible thing you
can do an error situation is
to say, well, did
I screw up here?
And you can insert
some debugging code
that says, if an
exception gets thrown,
if there's a 400 or 401,
you can use this token info
URL to be able to
validate that you actually
did get the right type of token.
A very common error is
that a token doesn't
have the right scope,
or the token is expired.
So you need to have
a valid OAuth token
before you can make API calls.
So that's just a little trick
that I like to show people.
So again, to recap, there's
a document on how to do this.
It's called "Using OAuth 2.0
for Client-side Applications."
You can just search
for that title.
And another tool is the
OAuth 2.0 Playground.
Typically, in these
situations, you only ever
need to implement
it one time, and you
don't need to worry
about this again.
You save the refresh
token, and you
can keep making calls
with the access token.
So before I go,
I'm going to show
you guys one more trick,
which is that the OAuth 2.0
Playground uses the client
ID ad client secret-- it's
one of our client ID
and client secrets.
So if you want to see the full
request and response using
your own client ID and
your own client secret,
click here under Settings.
And you can see that there's
different settings here.
Most of the time, the one
that you want to change
is Force approval prompt or
Use your OAuth credentials,
and this is where you would
plug-in your own client ID
and client secret that you're
getting from the API console.
Because once you get this, you
can start making API calls.
And you can compare these
against your own API calls
to see what the difference is.
And hopefully, that'll
help you guys debug.
So that's all I have
for you guys today.
Hopefully, this helps you
guys with any problems
you may have as you're trying
to figure out what's going on
with your OAuth tokens, and
help you authorize so you can go
ahead and build great
YouTube applications.
All right.
Thank you all very much.
And have a great day.